[Applause]
[Music]
if you lead the Seven Kingdoms will
follow Hello friends and welcome to the
big ticket interview for Aquaman and the
lost kingdom I am sitting next to the
Stars Jason Mamoa and Patrick Wilson and
I have been practicing holding my breath
for this deep dive guys ah see what you
did jokes are going to get so much worse
from here um in all sincerity though as
I was prepping for this interview I was
thinking about how Aquaman wasn't really
taken as seriously until you held the
Triton he was pretty campy in the comics
we've seen parodies of him get made fun
of in shows like the boys to some people
Aquaman's like a funny fictional movie
from the show Entourage and it wasn't
until a decade after that that the both
of you really helped bring his story to
life so much so with like so many layers
and complexity that to this day Aquaman
is the highest grossing DC film of all
time and it's how about that how about
that and it's truly a
testament that just sounds so good with
your stuff um but it's truly a testament
to the both of your abilities and really
this entire teams to take something that
a lot of people thought was cheesy and
make us all go man this guy's pretty
cool so I'm excited to talk to you about
him uh starting with you Jason because I
feel like there's so much of you in him
I was reading that the exterior set of
Arthur's house was actually dressed with
your own motorcycles and I was thinking
about how like you're a dad and now
Arthur's a dad so what was it like for
you to infuse you know that Dad part of
you into Arthur this time around well I
think that's um you know after the first
one I wanted to um I I wrote a an idea
and pitched it to them because I think
it's beautiful to be like
this this
uh half man half superhero or half
Atlantean who doesn't want to be king
but is destined to be king at the same
time falls in love with a woman has to
you know take on these duties which he
doesn't know about he's been this
reluctant King for so long and he's kind
of a yeah you know just not the right
guy for it but he's he's destined to do
that and um have a baby while you're
doing all at the same time and then kind
of be like a single parent like like
just I knew anything single parent
that's my what my father was but um I
just liked that complexity of it and
just being humbled by taking advice from
my father like just how I was raised
with a single parent yeah and so there
was just a lot of things I wanted to
dive into for the character and also
with this
guy just getting over our differences
like having this idea like having a
brother knowing what he's like what it
would be like down there and just
imagining what Atlantis would be like
and just all
these this life that he never was raised
in and then to meet him and he's and
then to be able to go to be able to
overcome our differences to come
together and just what we all need like
to overcome our differences and realize
we need to come together to save
something that's that's greater than us
yeah and I think it's a really fun um
adventure and just I think people can
relate to it and so as an actor I wanted
to dive into those things and being a
father which are some of the better
parts of me and um to be able to share
that we're both fathers and um I think
it's just it just makes it
more human and I'm excited to see that
father side of you come out and also all
the Aquaman daddy memes that are going
to come out of like are you ready for
that I'm not ready for that I just don't
think that way cuz I'm old but um I
think it's really cool like I just got
to see I I just watched the movie with
my kids and it really was beautiful like
you get to see my character get pretty
excited watching his son talk to fish
and he's just like no one else has that
power and everyone makes fun of him
that's the reason why everyone is like
dude you talk to fish but I'm like why I
talk to the ocean I talk to everyone
that's in the ocean I think it's a it is
a beautiful gift and um he gets to see
his kid doing it and obviously I light
up because you just need to make it that
thing I've been alone for so many years
I'm like God the things I'm going to
show you the things that I that I've had
to keep to myself that no one can kind
of understand my power they make fun of
it I mean the whole movie starts with
this silly I mean it's like hey I'm
malol man I talk to fish people say
that's stupid but I'm like but it's not
I think it's pretty cool you know so
it's you know he's the laughing stock of
being a superhero but I hope we make it
fun and I mean that's the whole point of
it and also connecting with yeah
connecting with our environment
connecting with our world and animals I
mean they know way more than we do so I
think it's a you know if you stop making
fun of me it's actually a cool thing
yeah it is and we're confirming that
Aquaman is the daddy of the Justice
League for sure um but I don't know what
that means it's okay guys it's going
over he is isn't he he is only wow we
just W that just discovered that well
that's because we sit by a campfire
that's right and we're just connecting
right now um you know I I can't wait to
see that Dad part of you come out
through the character and also I know
you were born in Hawaii I was watching a
video of the premiere of Aquaman the
first movie that took place in Hawaii
and Jason you were doing a Maui Haka
chant and you got pretty emotional while
doing it uh I know that you guys got to
shoot some of this film in Hawaii unlik
the last film are we going to get to see
more of your heritage come through
through Arthur because that's my
favorite part about it yeah well it's
cool I mean I fought for it and you know
there's there's moments where it comes
through and then some of it we didn't
make the made The Cutting Room floor but
we we worked hard to try to have it in
there so there's so much of him in there
that's that's the thing about it is I
think because you had this you had this
Clean Slate because of all the history
with Aquaman that was really neither
here nor there we didn't have a frame of
reference like you like you mentioned
from TV shows or the the the opinion of
Aquaman so it really gave him this Clean
Slate to be like to to to to to pull the
character to him you know what I mean
and that's when the when he really uh
takes off because you see so much of his
personality and his heart you know um as
as an actor so when when you've got the
space to give of yourself you know and
he's got so many ideas clearly that made
it into the film you know the conception
of of of the sequel that you that's the
way to do it is when you can really just
shape the whole series around him it's
that's what makes it special and unique
because there's there's no there's no
one like him so perfectly said and you
feel that Vis through the screen but
also with you Mr Patrick Wilson you my
friend have such range I mean from
Broadway musicals to your directorial
debut for insidious The Red Door slaying
at it I love watching you as orm you
make him feel so Shakespearean in this
like operadic epic adventure that is
Aquaman and the lost kingdom last movie
you were the main villain this time
you're working side by side with Arthur
as brothers what was it like switching
that up for you and does does orm still
have resentment towards Arthur in this
movie well you'll have to see uh no
again said so well with the STA yeah
everything works with the stash and
shops I know it's ridiculous uh and I
love to say people say oh you going out
for something
nope g willer's p yeah no just for me um
well you know that was the thing with
the first film is even though he was he
was the the main villain I guess in the
in the in the first film you knew where
he was coming from you knew that he too
was fighting for his his fighting for
Atlantis fighting for what he believed
in fighting for the environment there's
a lot of of common bond between these
two even though they go about it
completely different ways they certainly
have that common Bond of protecting
their own um so it's actually just a
natural fit to sort of how how that
would translate into them now fighting
the main villain who's Black Manta so
you know but it's not all sunshine and
Roses it's certainly a pretty pretty
tumultuous relationship I mean but name
a better underwater Duo than Aquaman and
Ocean Master aside from Mermaid Man and
Barnacle Boy obviously solid solid
reference um I'm excited to see you guys
do that sort of buddy cop banter and I
hope we get to see scenes with you and
Yaya Abdul matin the second who plays
Black Manta as a fan of Watchmen Is Your
Night Owl too he's our latest Doctor
Manhattan it's so cool but equally
isolated that you guys both teamed up
with James Juan the legend who's known
for his horror film making you're
obviously celebrated as Ed Warren in The
Conjuring Universe um remind me to ask
you about this ghost in my apartment
later uh but this is James's second
superhero film at coming back after
directing the first one so what's the
best part about working with the James
Juan for both oh God I mean he works
with them all the
time I'm gonna start with him um yeah I
think this is my sixth movie with James
yeah um yeah I I what's exciting to see
if I go back just in my own history with
James and you know the first film that I
did with him which was the first
Insidious movie which was made for like
under a million dollars you know cut to
this movie that it's considerably more
um to see someone grow with he's
constantly pushing himself he's
constantly trying to push himself
technically um and emotionally I think
in movies so each movie he never wants
to do the same thing again so even
though we've come back to this world and
this character what can we do new with
him which I think is probably to the
point of Jason like okay let's take a
lot of Jason's ideas throw that into the
grinder with with what J brings to the
table and I think he's a person that
definitely has the focus and vision of
the kind of movie he wants to make but
um but I think like most great
collaborators he takes a lot of uh of of
I won't say advice but certainly ideas
uh from the from the room which is which
is a which is a real strength yeah yeah
I think he's a real Visionary I mean he
really comes in with them he builds
these worlds and so even even when I had
to switch over from Zach to to James you
know two totally different directors two
totally different
styles but nevertheless like really
World Builders and um he knows what he
wants and uh that's nice to be able to
know someone who's got a vision and
quite big Vision so and then once you
find your style
together and uh we work really well when
it's
um when we could like I think he's
pretty accepting for for everything like
you take notes really well I don't
I don't know and and um he's he's a
great actor he's a really great actor
and so it's it's a little more
challenging for me on sometimes and so
me and James have like on the second one
it's been really fun because there's two
different the first one is like such
different styles of how to do stuff like
what like it was very hard for me
to um I'm just a lot more free and stuff
like that and so once James knew once
James knew that he's like oh yeah just
let him play cuz that's where you're
going to find me at my best yeah and
then when I'm and and then he can rain
it in and he can really like more putty
it yeah where if I am uh told what to do
and like in a certain way you're losing
all the the best parts of me and then as
a insecure actor or a human yeah I kind
of go in where he's so free and it's
really beautiful to work with and he
helped me where it's just like he's just
like oh yeah I'll do that of course I'll
do that I'm like here to play I'm here
to play and where for me as a I haven't
acted as long as him he really or his
experience I get to learn a lot from him
in that so um but we found we've really
found that in this one where it's funny
yeah it's fun and and it's fun being
with him a and Yaya's amazing it sucks
cuz he's a bad guy but I'm like we have
a lot of fun he's and he's phenomenal in
it I think he's really beautiful and
strong in it so we have a really good
thing going so and I feel like James
just uh he got to just kick back and
watch us play and he built the whole
world for us to play in so yeah it's
good point you guys feel like real
brother sitting next to you and I love
your answer to that that was so like
vulnerably shared and I feel you a fire
sign I know you're a seven on the enag
and you're a Leo does that mean I don't
know is that your energy type and they
love freedom anyways my seven out of who
what seven C's anyways back to the
interview uh you mentioned World
building with James W he's such a master
at World building right but this man's
also just such a genius at scary stuff
the trench scene from the first movie
lives rentree in all of our heads I I
still picture that Red Orb going deeper
and deeper into the ocean and all the
sea monsters surrounding it can you tell
us Jason about some of the new creatures
and worlds that we're going to meet and
explore in the lost kingdom I mean
there's there's uh I mean it's a whole
new slate so it's wonderful I mean like
look how diverse our ecosystem is now I
just made a film about deep sea Mining
and all the the what we've uncovered
with our cameras and what we can film
now and so it's wonderful to dive into
the the unknown like we don't know
anything about our deep and um so it's
it's beautiful to be able to take these
kids and go on an adventure and like
show all these new worlds so there's
there's quite a few and um I mean we're
in so many different environments from
the desert to like the dark jungle I was
reading about absolutely so D totally
total deab Vibes in there and the uh ice
you know and the uh I think we're in
every yeah yeah world too and with all
these worlds there's so many cool
effects that go with it and we've seen
such incredible technological Marvels
when it comes to underwater filming
recently in movies like Avatar 2 wakanda
forever I know for the first film you
guys use blue screen staging and tuning
fork framing uh for this film was there
anything different that you use this
time around
wise okay we're good we good St
L we no we did great for this this new
one it's like I couldn't believe you
just step in a box give a couple faces
theine the eyeline can you tell us more
about the eyeline studio you guys are
referring to a circular boot that was
yeah I think flash was the first one to
use it and then it went to us and it's
and what is it exactly I mean you step
into a uh a circular room circular room
with LEDs uh with with LED screens
around it so unlike when you
do the very lamous terms like when you
do motion capturing it basically
captures your bones right because you
got lights on them and they get you your
figure then they have to build around
that yeah um I'm totally bastardizing
this but I I I think it's true so you're
playing the scene and there's tons and
tons of cameras that are that are built
within this circle of LED screens so you
can play you're actually looking at kind
of like a cartoon version of you w yeah
yeah so but he but it captures
everything yeah but they'll you'll be
over there and I'm having the
conversation with you so go play Ang
you're basically inside a video game
you're inside a video game it sounds
like it was a lot more comfortable to
shoot this time around for you guys as
was the Aquaman suit that I was reading
about let's bring it back like this
Aquaman was a compared to like I had to
do Batman versus Superman I had to do
Justice League that was like that was
primitive
yeah well I'm so happy we got here um I
was also reading with the suit James
Juan looked to the Silver age comics for
a lot of the design and aesthetic for
this one and I love those Comics I love
that Arthur calls his baby Aqua baby in
those um but I was reading costume
designer Richard s said he used a lot of
lighter materials and that it took three
people three months to place each scale
onto your suit how do you feel wearing
it Jon like do you just feel like such a
badass in the suit well the first wait
why are you laughing because the first
week you're like yeah I mean it's you
put it on you you can't help but
transfer into this energy and and uh and
it's wonderful and then reality sinks in
you're like give me the out of this
thing because you're in your own soup
for all day and it weighs a lot like
there's no actor's chair you just lay
down like cuz you can't mess the outfit
up oh so you literally you can't bend
over you can't do anything I mean it
looks fabulous but you got you can't you
can't do anything that's what I have to
do every day and I have to have a fight
suit on because that we're just going to
tear them up so it's there's probably a
shift of people fixing it because I mean
I got to do these fights and you got to
run around and and and do you and and
it's not easy to do in the suit so I
mean kudos to you cuz there's nothing
more demoralizing than taking off a wetu
for me personally anyway and I have to
get out of stuff in between I have to
have those little breaks like be
comfortable it was like Will William
defo will like just park up and like
he'll be in but he's all like yoga mind
he would he's like he loved that he
didn't have any he he didn't have like
the tight muscle suit kind of like me on
on on this one basically like a costume
also he also weighs as much as my leg so
when we're hanging up by her I'm like
bro you can stay up here I'm like and
you have what three days work I'm I'll
be here for four more months that's so
funny yeah cuz Patrick yours was a start
contrast in the Royal costume we saw you
I saw your in like a near dark purple
sort of soldier atic yeah it's kind of
like a military looks good yeah it's
cool you wear the stash with it too
totally would been amazing oh you didn't
yeah no I did not U no yeah um yeah I
did not mine mine was easy on this film
I was I lucked out I L out I'm excited
to see them because costumes are my
favorite part of Aquaman in just like
any underwater world but for Jason I
know I speak for a lot of fans and I say
it's kind of gnarly for us to see you in
the suit because you just are Aquaman
protector of the seas in real life like
you founded an aluminum water bottle
company to end single plastic use can I
one you're a United Nations
environmental Ambassador for Life Below
water you mentioned you know a
documentary that you made Deep Rising
you also narrated one called Waterman
there it is
um no we just got these in theat theat
I'm super proud of that it is stunning
very thankful for uh DC and War Earth
you know joining in to help stop it you
know it's so cool like it really it's
for me it feels like where does where
does Jason end and Aquaman begin and
Patrick was kind of like talking about
that he must mean so much to you what
are you going to miss most about playing
Aquaman that's the one thing I was just
kind of it just kind of hit me yeah it's
I've been doing it for what 14 years I
mean I had to keep I had to keep Aquaman
a secret
for 3 years almost and it was just very
hard in my career at that time and Zach
saw um Game of Thrones and really gave
me a shot but I had to keep it quiet cuz
they were shooting Batman vers Superman
and I wasn't out or they were just doing
Superman and I wasn't out till quite a
bit like and I only had one scene in
that so just to think back then to go
like gosh I got wait 6 years until I get
to Justice League I to wait eight years
so I get to Aquaman if it even make and
I got to take this character who
everyone laughs at and make this guy and
and scary because if it fails I'm like
dude I'm not that's notes I'm already
don't I don't have any work little alone
so there was a lot and I've been with
this guy for a long time and I put a lot
of me into it and that's actually one I
sat with
fast Bender this a this is definitely a
fire a campfire moment but um fast
Bender is a good buddy of mine and we
were in London together and I was just
starting to do uh justice league and he
goes um you let the world in like show
them you put you into it yeah because
they're going to want you to play these
other things but you put you in there
and take your choices because that's
what's going to connect and they can't
write that they like and so when he
did that I I would just try to find
moments where I can put in things that
were honest to me yeah that would make
me just be honest and have and make
people have fun cuz I I was having fun
and so uh I kind of kept that going with
because these movies are hard you know I
mean and they're he's done X-Men and all
these other super you know he's done
that stuff and so it was a nice advice
just to put a little bit you in there
and then that's what you were talking
about
earlier but back to it is just going
like it's going to be sad cuz we're
actually the end of the DCU and it's
like it's it's a whole new you know it's
what 14 years of of of that whole
universe and it was fun playing them
we're all so proud of you do you think
this is the last time you'll be playing
Aquaman I think it'll be the last time
we play Aquaman yeah well I feel like I
wouldn't be doing my job if I didn't ask
you about Lobo cuz I know you've been
eyeing that character for a while well I
originally thought I was going to be
playing Lobo in the very beginning cuz I
got called in I auditioned for Batman
and I almost didn't do it cuz I was like
this is silly it's not going to be me
why am I auditioning for Batman but it
was just a of the mill audition right
and then I get called in right after and
a gets announced and I'm like oh of
course I'm going to play the play the
bad guy right there not too many guys
that can kick the out of those two so I
was like yeah I'll come in and beat him
up and uh die like I do sure good and
good D yeah you're a good d Mama and so
you're an incredible villain by the way
I mean Dante was well I don't get to
play villain that many times so that was
I I've only played villain twice and so
um anyways uh I got called in the office
and I was just like well do you do you
know who you're gonna play I'm like yeah
Lobo yeah of course he's the only one
that can fight Batman and Superman he's
like what Lobo I'm like no he's not in
this universe I was like what who the
hell am I supposed who the hell am I
supposed to play it's funny and man I
wish I wish he would have taped it cuz
he was like Aquaman I'm
like are you talking about I mean I
literally think of you instantly as orm
like that's what you would think and go
like yeah right like how he's like cuz I
and then he just told me his vision he's
like you're Polynesian like it would be
this and you're this mix and you're but
you live in Iceland and you go these
places and you're this traveler and you
you'll punch Batman in the face and
you'll kiss Wonder Woman you're just
like this Renegade yeah and you're this
king who just want I was like this is
awesome and he's like I want you to do
what you did on like so he just built it
in this way where I was like oh cool and
he's like I want your tattoo here po
your tattoos everyone I was like holy
man this guy's really been he
dreamed of pretty I mean you got to give
it to Zack he built you know it was an
unbelievable character that he came up
with and uh anyways yeah but so Lobo was
that's I colle I used to collect comics
and um I don't do so much anymore but um
he was always my favorite and I'm like I
would always wanted to play Lobo cuz I'm
like hello it's pretty like it's perfect
it's perfect role I mean listen if they
call me and ask me to play it's a it's a
yeah but I mean that's a guarantee so
you don't have to worry about that get
my own high five yeah yeah yeah so but
you know I haven't received that call so
I don't want to put any fake news out
there but if they ever call me and ask
me to play You're or ask me to audition
I'm I'm there I mean you're not going to
have to audition well I know
but I mean we're pass
that um well I I hope we get to see that
happen cuz he's so n as a '90s kid like
l so 90s we need it now we need it more
than ever we need it more than ever um
so yeah I mean at the end of the day as
Jules Vern said you know if you put two
ships in an open sea you know with wind
and the other thing that he says they'll
come together without wi that Jules burn
yes Jules bur I hope we get to see and I
have a feeling that we're going to get
to see the both of you in the same way
those two Ships Come Together come back
together I mean listen you're a Watchman
and you're in this and like he's a
chameleon he's so talented so I me like
yeah and may we work together for the
rest of our lives I just it's I'm I'm
excited to go on this this press stour
with him because it's it's fun and I
want to see it with him too so hopefully
it'll be a space where we can watch it
together and giggle and love that well
thank you both for putting your art and
love into these characters and Aquaman
stories and energy and thank you guys so
much for watching tickets to Aquaman and
the last kingdom are on sale right now
on pho.com my name is aspre and I can
finally stop holding my breath thanks
for watching thank you wonderful job
thank you guys
fantastic